i hack things apart I combine things
that aren't a natural fit tinkering is
kind of where this all started when it
comes to making and the DIY movement
there's little debts as cool as robotics
and anyway Wong is a master of hacking
things apart putting them together again
and coming up with brand new creations
anyway tell me about what you do I guess
what I'm best known for is steam power
stuff you know so I take old steam
engines and your model steam engines and
I kind of hacking into different
machines and just kind of fantasy based
kind of things but in real life they
actually work so that's that's kind of
part of the appeal for me is just adding
some character and personality into the
machine
so on this machine take me through the
different components of it what are the
parts that are the steam parts without
their what other functions and how does
it work this is the boiler and this is
where I'll be filling it with water a
little bit oil for the the engine I
filled this up with the nature alcohol
and set on fire and that he turns boils
the the water inside here it gets piped
into this low steam engine and then it
starts working
so then after you worked on some of
these steam-powered RC vehicles I know
you've got a bunch of these smaller
creations yeah how did how did these
come about the goal here for me is just
kind of create like believable
personalities you know with these little
things so once you see them move it
looks like a little critter these work
off of tiny little micro servos running
off a battery and I'm controlling it
with a transmitter I notice one of these
looks like it doesn't have electric or
steam-powered
this this Walker over here what's the
story with that yeah so this is the
hamster Walker so this is a hamster ball
and a hamster goes in there it's a
walking machine powered by a hamster do
you have a hamster
my niece does so and ya have access to
it I'm sorry
and it works yeah she's a great runner
so how fast does this thing get going
she comes out pretty pretty good pace
that's the the former power of the
future yeah there we go good we've
solved the energy crisis
you